let's just talk about okay we've got
this recount thing
oh we'll wait on this for a little bit
so that people can start you know coming
into the
into the live show about let's just talk
about what happened with this clip with
andy no
to start things off so andy no post you
may know him he's a journalist he's on
twitter he posted this clip
where there's this this guy looks seems
to be a trump supporter
and someone comes up behind him and
sucker punches him from behind just
knocking him out to the ground and then
some people start kicking his face
kicking him in the head they pick him up
and this dude's gone man he's just like
out of it he's bleeding
and then all of a sudden andy no starts
trending on twitter
because these leftists were like show
the full clip you didn't show the full
clip
and so then people start sharing this
longer version that shows this guy who
got sucker punched
walking up to the leftist and the guy
with a bullhorn and swinging at him and
shoving him saying see
he started the fight and you see that
wasn't even the full clip either
the full clip was that a couple guys
tried leaving uh
and the cops wouldn't let him so they
were forced to walk through the crowd
and the crowd harassed and
swung at him and shoved him and attacked
him for like a couple blocks
it's like one really long block you can
see this video and these guys are even
begging like please like we're not doing
it
we're trying to leave doesn't matter
they're getting up in their space
they're hitting them shoving them
finally they turn a corner this guy came
and started defending people
it would seem i'll ask you like if that
makes sense because i watch the full
thing from start to finish
but this is what happens andy no post
this clip saying dude this guy got
sucker punched
the left claims he's purposefully taking
out out of context when i think he was
just trying to highlight the sucker
punch
then they only show an out of context
clip not explaining why it was this guy
confronted this group
but it seems like this guy was trying to
defend people who were being attacked is
that
true is that yeah so basically just what
what happened to him is
um you know the the regular event
happened it was
you know peaceful like jack was saying
it was thousands of people there i mean
i would
i'm guessing yeah i would say maybe like
half a million and
really uh yeah it was it was it was a
lot of jackson
i mean i'm not an expert on this meaning
i'm not an expert but it was more than a
hundred
grand a hundred thousand people that i
would say um you know
started off the event you know regular
people marching showing their support
for trump
and um around two or three i call this
journalistic
instinct was i said i should probably
make my way down to black lives matter
plaza because if there's anything that's
going to happen it's going to happen at
that plaza
as soon as i arrived at the plaza i
filmed this uh
video where uh what what originally
caught my attention was
it's a family that was supporting trump
you know they had like their trump gear
on
they're walking through the uh black
lives matter plaza as they're walking
through
i was speaking to another reporter but
what caught my attention about the
family was that
that that their daughter had her head
down and she was really in distress she
was crying
and she was shaking so i was like okay
hold on so i turn my camera on and focus
on her and as soon as i did that
these black lives matter supporters
start approaching the family yelling at
them
that's when the mom grabs her daughter
and he pulls her in close and basically
a a huge clash happened he then um
then one of the black lives matter you
know supporters they pushed the dad onto
that daughter so that she like hits this
concrete slab that was there
she's crying it was you know it was an
emotional scene it was even tough as a
reporter to document that because
there were kids involved um so
originally what the cops did then after
that
that event was they said all right what
we're gonna do is we're gonna shut off
every street into black lives matter
plaza to stop the trump supporters from
colliding with with the uh black lives
matter supporters which originally was a
great idea
and but what happened was is that these
trump supporters then couldn't get
through to their hotel
so then what i did is i walk up to a
police line this is on i in 16th street
on black
matter plaza and uh the guy's name is
christopher now that i found that he
actually ended up dming me on twitter
him and his wife and i believe a couple
other of his uh people in this group are
begging
the cops please let us through and
before they even walk up to the police
line they were already getting harassed
they walk up to the police line the
police don't let him through and he says
no you gotta you gotta go around as soon
as the police um
you know turn them around they get
attacked as they're getting attacked the
police line is just looking at them
letting this happen
um that's when i filmed the uh
african-american female with that with
the orange
shower cap abundant whatever you want to
call it she punches a dude from the
behind
these people were scared for their lives
they kept saying like look we just want
to get back to our hotel so
they're getting attacked and then that's
when um they kind of walk down the
street and then that's when we see
that gentleman went this long black uh
shirt on orange riding
he like comes in and kind of like tries
to defend this group
that's when we see him take the
microphone away then he like pushes that
guy on the ground i believe he like even
stepped on his head
and then that's when the group kind of
closed in on him and at this time still
with all this commotion police are not
stepping in
then the guy gets sucker punched by uh
it was the african-american gentleman
with the uh trump pence out
now uh signed the guy gets knocked out
and another individual comes
and uh takes three steps on his head he
then then they finally picked him up and
then take him to the police line
then the police get involved so um it
was just like a
a hectic situation i think what what
people didn't understand maybe who
weren't there and
you know the whole out of context thing
is that these trump supporters were
getting attacked on their way to the
hotel they were literally just mining
their business they were literally
pleading with the police that they could
let be be let through and the police
basically
uh kind of you know from my uh
perspective they failed these people
because they didn't even
not only did they point them to the
wrong direction but at least
escort these people to their hotel i
mean these police are from dc it's no
secret what's going on the political
atmosphere but um yeah tim i think uh
i think uh it was just a hectic
situation i think people don't don't
understand the force
you saw the response to andy now's tweet
though right yep is it fair to say that
the left response
with this with a short clip was also out
of context it was also out of context i
think what the leftists understand is
let's say that guy comes in and you know
pushes his man in the microphone it
still doesn't excuse you to
literally brutally knock out this guy
then stomp on his head
uh i mean he kicked some dude in the
head too right yeah so i i i was on the
whole mob he fought a bunch of guys he
swung and went into the crowd and back
and out backing out again
and i don't know this for sure but from
just being there i'm assuming that that
guy
saw those people getting attacked and
saw that they were being ganged up on
saw that they were ripping the trump
flag
and i'm assuming he just got sick of it
and wanted it to step in
and it seemed like he was protecting him
as as he engaged with them the family
got away
yeah so you have a family the police
won't let him through
i think it's funny too i think a lot of
uh a lot of trump supporters people who
don't live in big cities don't realize
how police are going to treat you
and they think they can walk to the cops
and be like howdy officer my hotel's
right there and the cop says i don't
care
get out of my face in fact i'm sir i'm
sure some of these people get a rude
awakening
with the cops even just shoving them or
saying shut up or not even responding to
him
because you know if you're from a city
you probably get it if you're in a
protest cop is going to be like
don't care at all those cops don't know
the protesters are
they don't know the trump supporters are
they don't know what they're protesting
they don't know what they're supporting
don't care got orders nobody goes
through done you could be a journalist
it doesn't matter yeah i watched them
arrest a guy in a suit at occupy wall
street who was walking out of a bodega
with an orange
fanta it was like a famous story that
happened he walks out
and there's a crowd of protesters and
he's like wearing a suit and he's all
just like oh this is crazy
they arrest him and he's freaking out
like what's going on apparently he
showed up to court
screaming about how he was at work went
outside to go grab a soda from the
bodega and the cops arrested him
even though he's clearly not a protester
so
i have some extra color on that story so
i was down in black lives matter i was
down there
my job that day was to record but also
scout that was what i wanted to do i
wanted to go on the fringes be up front
and just see
where black where antifa was going to be
what the plan was who how and when they
were going to maybe
assault people and i had been tweeting
for days beforehand safety alert please
stay in the suburbs please at night go
back to the suburbs arlington is very
close
jackpot sobek tweeted out ali alexander
did we tried to warn people like we
legitimately tried to warn people and i
think
people got the message i mean that one
tweet was seen by like a half a million
times so like
people saw it so i went to black lives
matter plaza after
the march had gone from freedom plaza
all the way down to supreme court i
walked all the way back
and the guy who knocked out this guy in
question
i was there he approached me it must
have been a half hour an hour before
that incident and he was like
just insane the leftist guy the leftist
guy who knocked the dude out at that
registered sex offender
registered sex offender he was insane he
was looking for people to assault he
came up to me like he was going to get
me
i had a security guard with me that day
he just stepped in and pushed the guy
back
he kind of like looked and he was like
yeah maybe not the antifa guys that
that costed me the previous week at the
other riot
where the cops saved me they were there
they recognized me they were all like
scheming getting ready to see what they
could do to me
um but the cops did save me that one
night so like it's
kind of yeah but there was like it was
imminent and i was ganged up by like 30
people and i was the only one there but
anyway
those people were there looking looking
to assault people
looking to harass people looking to hurt
people not looking to protest not
looking to
make a chant they were looking for
violence and this
was a conversation we're having earlier
there's there's definitely blm down
there there's definitely antifa down
there there's definitely just sort of
rando lefties down there
but there's also just random thugs yeah
right people just want violence
he feels good just want violence and uh
that incident was horrible to see
and then did you see some chick some
lady stole his phone
too at the very end it was it was on
film he's face down blood coming out of
his face and the girl steals his phone
so if i could add to him
basically um that guy gets knocked out
he he gets taken to the cops and then
the commotion is still
ongoing we then basically wrap around
the street
and then we see an elderly couple
walking back to their hotel and then
that's when we see this group
attack that couple try to steal their
trump flag oh yeah a big problem
to that older that older lady because
she's held onto it
she didn't give it up either they were
they were literally attacking this
elderly couple you could hear one of the
guys um you know yelling at them saying
you're so lucky the cops are not here i
would you know beat the f out of you
whatever
and it was just crazy to like just
you know sit you know being there
documenting that and then one of the uh
females who stole the phone
uh i believe she had also had a taser
she was actually trying to tase
kailyn from scriber news who who was
just on
on on the show she was trying to taze
him um unsuccessfully thank god
then um basically everything was
happening so fast me and caitlin kind of
went to the side and then
we told the cops hey we have all the
video footage of the assault
they were the ones responsible so i do
want to credit the
dc police in this area because they saw
our footage
right away and then made the arrest like
in real time in
in front of me and caitlin's faces so
they made they made the arrest of the
individuals who were
responsible for the for the assad i
believe they got like two or three that
are
are wanted but um the folks who were you
know heavily involved they arrested them
there in real time i believe
the uh the two males who arrested did
have weapons
on them the female had a taser then we
found out that one of the
uh men were already a registered sex
offender so thanks to andy noe
for getting that information but uh
absolutely several guns but
yeah they recovered like i think but it
makes you but it makes you
think tim that like you know i don't
want to this is not me taking any credit
or killing for us but it's just like if
me and ken aren't there to like pressure
the cops to arrest these people showing
that we have video evidence and that we
and prove that we are credentialed media
you know these people would have
got away and just would have kept doing
that all night
so these videos are crazy man uh you
have this massive crowd of trump
supporters but as night falls and the
numbers start thinning out
then these leftists and just like jack
was saying violent people looking for a
fight
yeah get to come out and do whatever
they want you can see they look in their
eyes do you know that guy in particular
i was chest to chest with him moments
before he assaulted that guy you could
see it in their eyes they're just crazed
i went down looking to her i went down
i'll add to this this is great um we
were down there
andreas and i went down walked around so
we did the parade during the day walked
up and down had lunch with some of the
infowars people and then we were out
it's starting to get dark
when we're black lives matter plaza and
dude it was like tim's metaphor is great
like you ever play a game where there's
a horde mode
but it glitches and you get in the back
room where the horde's waiting before
they get released
just a bunch of people like standing
there not making noise not saying
anything
like they're not protesting dudes would
be like just sitting there looking at
you with their other all black
and so it felt like a horde was about to
be unleashed yeah i i used to
do like i used to design games when i
was younger and when we would create
uh when you create bad guys like in
video in a video game you're playing
right a bad guy comes through the door
and he runs at you
there's actually you can't see it behind
this is probably just a big empty space
where they drop all of the various bad
guys
and then they have a scripted cue where
it's like at this interval with this
trigger they come out
and if you ever glitch through it
they're all just standing there
mindlessly doing nothing and that's what
ian was describing i was like
dude sounds like you went into the back
area before the
you know horde mode started and all
these digits waiting there not just like
getting ready to go
it was a tweet from jack murphy that
said all my maga friends get out of dc
nothing good is going to go and i'm not
maga but i read that like i think i'm
going to i think
yeah then so jack pasok too was sending
tweets like get out of the city get us
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time